muy buenos días pues se hubo reacciones
sobre todo de su familia política de los
republicanos partidos de derecha que
justamente después de conocerse está
este fallo pues salieron en defensa de
nicolás sarkozy diciéndole que lo
apoyaban y que creían que creían en el
este fallo bueno en el que lo condenan a
un año de prisión firme por esa y en
financiación ilegal de su campaña de
2012 y es la pena más alta que podría
recibir por este cargo de hecho la
presidenta del tribunal explicó pues que
él estaba ya digamos en su segunda
campaña presidencial así que él estaba
muy al corriente de cuál era el tope que
no podía sobrepasar que era de uno de
unos veinte puntos cinco millones de
euros y a pesar de esto ya pesar de que
ya había dos contadores que le habían
lanzado alertas diciéndole que los que
su campaña iba a pasar ya sobre costos
pues él continuó pidiendo que se
lograran que se consiguieran más mítines
de campaña que se siguieran organizando
estos estos mítines de campaña de gran
además uno de ellos que incluso habían
costado hasta cinco millones de euros